we had this woman there's no polite way
to say it she had been passed around the
jackass cast and
uh and Pon and I even shared her at one
time at the same time at the same time
it was a New Year's Day we ended up back
in my apartment with this young lass we
were on the pull out sofa in the living
room wow and this remarkable occurrence
happened where we both emitted both of
our seans and it land it landed on this
woman at the exact same time and that
was when she said I wish I had two
mouths because that would have saved her
from turning her head back and forth oh
my God NE oh my God yeah but this woman
in particular had identified Henry
Rollins as a love interest we're both
huge Rollins flag fans we love Rollins